every day like wake up kick-ass repeat
wake up again yep we are digging deep
into J Lo's beauty secrets first the
Plus sent to facial she reportedly gets
at four hundred and fifty dollars per
treatment the process uses sheep stem
cells to rejuvenate skin also on J Lo's
regimen she does Sun she doesn't drink
and she stays away from caffeine what
she does do a lots of veggies and a lots
of fleet in the process it's a pride you
know first of all I just have fun with
it I don't overthink it I think a lot
and how about those ABS I love the
dancing and definitely I don't love the
gym as much as I love the dancing so
it's a good thing for it for my ABS but
our biggest takeaway from JLo at 47 be
you at any age I refuse to be put in a
box in that way do you know what I mean
why because I'm over 40 so it can't be
sexy or is it because I'm a mom moms
aren't allowed to be sexy women at a
certain age really start to blossom I
didn't even know who I was in my 20s and
early they're acting honestly but I do
know who I am now well said my friend
will says